What do you know about Argentina?
Perhaps its food: wine, meat, dulce de leche.
Or its culture: the tango, Borges, the city
of Buenos Aires.
But there’s a part of Argentina that you
probably know very little about.
From 1976 to 1983, Argentina was ruled by
one of the most BRUTAL dictatorships in the
history of Latin America.
It was a regime, supported and funded by the
United States, that engaged in one of the
most violent and ruthless campaigns of extermination
in the entire twentieth century.
Argentina had been marked by political instability
since 1955, when the military overthrew President
Juan Perón and banned his party from taking
part in national elections.
In the meantime, left-wing guerrillas emerged.
Perón returned to the country in 1973, and
was reelected president.
When he died the next year, his wife, Isabel,
took power.
Amidst an economic crisis, the government
supported right-wing paramilitary groups in
order to fight the guerrilla movement.
Political violence became a top concern.
Right after midnight on March 24th, 1976,
the Argentine military arrested Isabel Perón,
occupied radio and TV stations, and released
their first statement: the country was now
under military rule.
They promised to restore the country to order
and end the violence.
They even called the new government “the
National Reorganization Process.”
Some believed in that promise.
The American ambassador called it “the best
executed and most civilized coup in Argentine
history.”
To the American ambassador, the coup’s leader—a
general named JORGE RAFAEL VIDELA—was a
“moderate” who could “defeat the left-wing
terrorists.”
After all, the generals who executed the coup
were trained by the U.S. military at the School
of the Americas.
But they had something bigger in mind.
Beecause, in the end, they had come to do
way more than fight the guerrillas, whom they
crushed within a few months.
For them, “terrorism” meant anything that
went against their vision of a pure society.
Many of them harbored fascist sympathies.
Videla himself declared: “a terrorist is
not only someone with a weapon or a bomb,
but anyone who spreads ideas which are contrary
to our Western and Christian civilization.”
So the generals sought to “disappear”—kidnap,
imprison, torture, kill—everyone they saw
as a threat.
That meant not only those involved in resistance
activities, but also trade unionists, Jews,
writers, homosexuals, even priests and nuns
who worked among Argentina’s poor.
This was their opportunity to “PURIFY”
Argentine society—by force.
The military called this repression La Guerra
Sucia: “the Dirty War,” a war against
a “hidden” enemy in which ANY means were
justified.
Argentina became a theater in a regional terror
campaign called “OPERATION CONDOR.”
Right-wing dictatorships across Latin America—not
just Argentina but also Chile, Paraguay, Uruguay,
and Brazil—pursued a RELENTLESS CAMPAIGN
of torturing and murdering leftists.
These regimes murdered tens of thousands of
dissidents in the most brutal fashions imaginable.
And it was all backed, even funded, by the
United States.
In fact, in 1976, American Secretary of State
Henry Kissinger met with the new regime’s
foreign minister.
The Argentine minister thought that Kissinger
would lecture him about the military’s violence.
But Kissinger did not raise the subject.
When the minister asked, Kissinger responded
that they should simply “clean up the problem.”
According to the State Department, the Argentines
saw Kissinger’s words as a “green light”
to do whatever they pleased.
After the meeting with Kissinger, the repression
accelerated.
The Argentine military built clandestine detention
camps across the entire country to house political
prisoners.
There, prisoners were tortured to obtain information
about other political activists.
The torture techniques employed by the military
were brutal: rapes, electric prods, beatings.
After torture, prisoners were killed, and
their bodies were burned or buried in mass
graves.
The Argentine military soon became famous
for their so-called “death flights,” where
prisoners were boarded on a plane, stripped
naked, and dropped over the ocean, with their
bodies sometimes washing up on the beaches
around Buenos Aires.
Even pregnant women were tortured.
In many cases, the military executed them
after giving birth, stole their children,
and gave them to military families.
At the same time, the Argentine military government
implemented a harsh system of “economic
reform.”
The program was received with praise from
Wall Street: the president of Chase Bank,
David Rockefeller, called it “brilliant,
solid and absolutely realistic.”
Rockefeller was a personal friend of the regime’s
Minister of Economy, Martínez de Hoz.
Argentina abolished price controls, froze
wages, liberalized the financial markets,
and ended industrial protectionist measures.
It was a rapid neoliberal transformation of
the economy.
And the consequences of that reform were disastrous.
In one year, the real wages of Argentine workers
fell 30 percent.
Argentine industry went into a deep crisis,
and living standards plummeted.
One famous journalist, Rodolfo Walsh, wrote
of the effect of these policies on the Argentine
people in an “Open Letter” to the military
regime.
During this first year of government, consumption
of food has decreased by 40 percent, consumption
of clothing by more than 50 percent, and the
consumption of medicine is practically at
zero among the lower class.
“The results” of the policies, he wrote,
“have been devastating.”
The day after he wrote those words, Walsh
was gunned down in the street by the government’s
soldiers.
They never returned the body.
And in both its violent repression and its
economic “reform,” the Argentine government
had the firm support of the United States
and the International Monetary Fund.
In 1976, the U.S. gave Argentina $50 million
in “security assistance,” while the IMF
extended a new loan.
In 1977, the U.S. provided about $700,000
to train hundreds of Argentine military officers.
And in 1978, the U.S. sold $120 million in
military parts to Argentina.
It was only in the middle of President Jimmy
Carter’s term that the United States began
to question its role in funding the Argentine
dictatorship.
An American diplomat, Patricia Darien, wrote
a report detailing the extent of the Argentine
government’s brutality.
She said:
The electric picana, something like a supercharged
cattle prod, is still apparently a favorite
tool [of torture], as is the ‘submarine’
treatment (immersion of the head in a tub
of water, urine, excrement, blood, or a combination
of these).
But others in the U.S. did not care.
A California politician named RONALD REAGAN
responded that Darien should “walk a mile
in the moccasins” of the Argentine generals
before criticizing them.
Reagan said that “the incarceration of a
few innocents…is NO REASON to open the jails
and let the terrorists run free.”
Kissinger went to Argentina as General Videla’s
personal guest, and praised his so-called
“efforts in combating terrorism.”
In response to the revelations of torture
and murder, the Carter administration cut
aid to Argentina—from $30 million to $15
million.
But after 1979 the U.S. government CONTINUED
to back the Argentines as the leaders of anti-communist
repression in the Americas, even looking the
other way as they trafficked money through
the United States to fund death squads in
Central America.
And when Reagan became president in 1981,
American support became more explicit.
A leading general, Leopoldo Galtieri, was
invited to Washington, and Reagan sought to
resume arm sales and loans to Argentina.
An official in the Reagan Administration named
ELLIOT ABRAMS later admitted that he knew
that the Argentine government was stealing
babies from prisoners and giving them to military
officers, but did nothing.
But in 1982, amid a failing economy and growing
protests, the military government decided
to salvage their popularity by invading the
Malvinas Islands, a territory occupied by
Britain.
But they made a big mistake.
The U.S. was forced to side with Britain,
and Argentina was left isolated.
The war went terribly, and the Argentines
were quickly defeated.
With the economic crisis, the brutal repression,
and the failure of the Malvinas War, criticism
of the military became more open.
By the end of 1983, the military government
fell, and a new, democratic government was
elected.
The new government put the military on trial.
The JUICIO A LAS JUNTAS—“the trial of
the juntas”—was unique in the region.
But after the trial ended, right-wing violence
forced the president to set HUNDREDS of torturers
free, imprisoning only the generals.
And in the 1990s, President Carlos Menem—a
neoliberal tied closely to the United States—even
pardoned the generals.
It was only when leftist governments were
elected in the 2000s that many of the generals
were imprisoned again.
In 2010, Videla died in a prison cell in Buenos
Aires.
Still, the trauma remains fresh.
The survivors of the prison camps, the families
of the tens of thousands killed, the children
of the disappeared are alive and with us.
In Argentina, it remains an open wound—very
alive, and very painful.
But the story was different in the United
States.
No one who supported the tortures and murders
in Argentina—from Henry Kissinger to Ronald
Reagan—was punished.
Elliot Abrams served in the U.S. government
as recently as 2021.
EVERYONE got away with it.
Those wounds, too, remain fresh.
I’m Pablo Pryluka, PhD student at Princeton
University, for the Gravel Institute.